أهلا أهلا أنا النحلة
جئت إليكم أحمل عسلا
حلوا وشهيا ومفيدا
للصحة هو دوما أغلى
أهلا أهلا أنا النحلة جئت إليكم أحمل عسلا
حلوا وشهيا ومفيدا للصحة هو دوما أغلى
نحلة نحلة نحولة  *** نحلة نحلة نحولة
غابات أسكن وحقولْ ***  أنا بين الأزهار أصولْ
بنشاط وبحيوية ***  أعمل بتفان وأقولْ
أنا النحلة
زن زن زن
أهلا أهلا أنا النحلة
جئت إليكم أحمل عسلا
حلوا وشهيا ومفيدا
للصحة هو دوما أغلى
أهلا أهلا أنا النحلة جئت إليكم أحمل عسلا
حلوا وشهيا ومفيدا  للصحة هو دوما أغلى
في عسلي للناس شفاء ***  من أمراض أو أدواء
ورحيقا أجمعه بجد ***   أجعله لي أشهى غذاء
أنا النحلة
نحلة نحلة نحولة  *** نحلة نحلة نحولة
أنا دوما أسعى في حركة  ***   رمز للخير وللبركة
والأجمل بين الحشرات ***  حيوني نحولة الملكة
أنا الملكة
أهلا أهلا أنا النحلة  جئت إليكم أحمل عسلا
حلوا وشهيا ومفيدا  للصحة هو دوما أغلى
نحلة نحلة نحولة  *** نحلة نحلة نحولة